in Santorini our meekness it can be easy
to get lost
winding roads twisting stairs and narrow
streets can make the city's hard to
navigate on top of that the region is
made up of just two colors white and
blue the bright blue roofs contrasted by
whitewashed walls are an iconic image of
Greece people initially think the colors
originated from the Greek flag are the
bright blue evil eye but actually the
color scheme originated for a different
reason but first it's important to note
that although the colors can be a symbol
for the entire country white walls
paired with bright blue trimmings are a
trademark of the Cyclades which are a
group of Greek islands that include
Santorini Mykonos and Naxos it's also
important to note that Greece wasn't
always white and blue the buildings are
made up of stone mud and volcanic
material which makes them a darker color
locals would use natural ingredients and
lime plaster to add colors to their
buildings for example iron oxide turned
white into a tinted pink if you added
autre you'd get a yellow hue so the
Cyclades ended up being painted on a rad
of earth tones but when Ionis Metaxas
came to power in the 1930s he ordered
all of the buildings to be plastered
with white lime lime was thought to have
antibacterial properties that could
prevent the spread of diseases lime was
also inexpensive and reflected sunlight
that kept the buildings cool during the
summer sea blue originated from a
cleaning agent called la Lakai this was
found and pretty much every home across
Greece a couple tops of this mixed with
lime and you have the bright blue color
we know today when metaxas died the
islands transitioned back to the variety
of natural colors but during the
military dictatorship of 1967 it became
a law for all of the islands buildings
to be blue and white the color showed
patriotism unification and support for
the country's political agenda at the
time
the combination is also historically
known to symbolize white waves crashing
in the Aegean Sea and the blue of the
Greek sky decades later the iconic image
has become ingrained in our minds
although the laws are no longer in place
a majority of the buildings have kept
the traditional color combination so now
if you see the Cyclades from a bird's
eye view you'll notice a blur of bright
white and bold blues dotting each Island
if you visit don't be afraid to get lost
exploring the Cyclades picturesque color
scheme is all part of the fun
[Music]
you